what's up guys my name is samuel lees
thank you so much for coming to youtube
you know what i'm just doing my team
right now
you're an amazing team and um listen if
you grow in a business
there's three things you need to do
three s's okay number one
is you need to scrap jobs that do not
need to be done
okay there's three things you need to do
jobs they'll be good with the next first
scrap them
so we're looking at jobs we're going
through things like actually you know
what
no one needs to do that job no one needs
to do that thing we can just scrap it
so many times people do things in
business that actually
don't need doing they don't need doing
so what i want you to do right now
is i want to look at your business maybe
your maybe you are
um doing things like okay you're doing
rent to rent business okay
or you're trying to get below market
value deals to source and
you go around viewing like 100 houses
offering 20 below market value on stuff
and all that's happening is you're
getting rejected rejected rejected
rejected
over and over and over again and you
think actually i don't need to view 100
houses
i need to just pick up the phone and go
view somehow
and and then talk to the agent and just
put some if wood offers instead
maybe i need to just do pre pre-offers
over the phone
like a pretty close rather than actually
going and viewing
100 houses as soon as you view 100
houses
and you just you just waste your time
their time everyone's time it's like
selling to someone
maybe maybe i'm picking up the phone and
i'm ringing all these cold leads trying
to sell to them trying to sell my
products or services maybe i should stop
doing that
stop scrap scrap the job maybe i should
only
be talking to people that are actually
warm and maybe i need to get them to go
through
fill out a questionnaire before i even
talk to them
so i can just eliminate that job once
and for all scrap next is
um staff get your staff to do stuff
and um well like honestly if you are
wanting to grow a large business you
need staff like
um and here's what i mean by staff you
might be thinking staff
uh oh man employing people and you don't
need to do that you can start by just
getting a gardener stop cutting your own
lawn
and get a garden to start cutting the
lord you can start by getting somebody
to
um getting a virtual assistant from the
philippines to do some of your admin
work
you know you're getting staff someone
else to do your jobs for you and
you need to know how much you're worth
per hour if you're worth
uh if you're worth 10 pounds an hour
then you need to make sure that you
don't do anything that's
that's been done that's less than 10
miles an hour if you're worth 100 pounds
an hour
then why would you why would you do a
job
that's that that's not worth your time
wealthy people know that time is money
time's important see we've got some of
our stuff around here right now also
some people
on the call these guys are
self-isolating because they traveled
they traveled um or not unauthorized
unauthorized unauthorized travel now
they're having to self isolate
so that's the second thing so firstly
scrap eliminate the jobs that don't need
doing
second is um get stats to do stuff
um get started stuff and then the third
thing is
systemize so you shouldn't even get
staff to do stuff that you can just
systemize
so an example of that would be um let's
say
let's say an investor okay at the moment
you get every time
someone clicks on your website an
interested investor clicks on your
website
what you do is you you pick up the phone
and you call them and you say hey
investor
thank you so much for coming on my
website i'd like to ask you some
questions to work out what kind of an
investor you are
what kind of deals you're looking for
and then you ask them some questions
takes up your time and then you think
actually i don't need to do that
maybe i can scrap that but it is really
important so i'll get staff members do
instead
uh i'll get a staff member to do instead
but actually you don't need to do that
either
you can systemize it so an example of
this would be this is one of the things
i learned
when i started deal sourcing and i was
doing exactly that i was ringing up
investors and i was asking loads of
questions and i thought actually why
don't i
get a website and get a landing page
where it just does an automatic it does
an automatic little questionnaire thing
so what you can do someone clicks on the
website
and it says hey join my mailing list and
then they join the mailing list
and then it says great please answer
these questions how much money do you
have to invest
are you ready to buy right now if the
perfect property came along what kind of
house are you looking for
you know what's your maximum budget
whereabouts are you looking
and it asks these questions they fill it
out and it's all automatic
it saves you having to pick up the phone
so now you just look at the question as
every day you just say oh i've had ten
ten emails
uh they've come through systemized
automatic
and then you look at them and then you
can get your staff to find them and
really pre-qualify
and then suddenly you're only doing
things that actually make money the
things that really count
so you know i think it's really really
important as a business person
you're a property investor you're a
property entrepreneur you're a business
person
property investing is a business your
product or your service is your house
or if you're doing rent to rent your
services the guaranteed rent to the
landlord
your customer is your tenant or your
customer is the landlord
so you're in business and if you're in
business and you want to grow and you
want to scale
you need to make sure that you are
systemizing
your business you stop you're scrapped
in all the things that don't matter
and no one needs to do so much nonsense
done so many people do things they don't
need to do
and then you're going to get you're
going to get staff even if it's just
assistance to begin with
virtual assistants so i hope you found
this video helpful i'm going to be doing
more
videos around business as well because i
really believe it's important that
people actually understand that this is
a business
how to run the business scale the
business that should be the fourth s
and uh let me know what type of content
you want to sit see i run i run a pretty
big company
i've got a property company i'm a
property entrepreneur i've i've run
letting agents i've managed hundreds and
hundreds of properties
i've sold hundreds of properties i've
developed a lot of houses not hundreds
but i've developed a fair few
and um anything you want to learn
anything you want to know
comment below i'll do my best to make
videos that help you to become
financially independent in your
property investment business thanks for
watching subscribe